at last the extra survival kits have
arrived for the offshore wind farm
we only had one survival pack for six
people
if a storm blows up out of the blue and
we can't be picked up by boat then we
have enough food to stay on the facility
for two or three days
when we go offshore with more than six
people we have to take additional
survival rations
everything is limited here at sea if you
forget something then you've forgotten
it you don't go back to collect
80 offshore managers are at a conference
on heligoland also on the program a
construction site visit
the head of wind mw wants his wind farm
to be ready first by the end of this
year
rwe and eon are hot on his heels
but these companies are not responsible
for connecting the turbines to the grid
it'll be a while before their
electricity is transported into people's
homes
there are problems with linking up to
the grid there isn't a connection yet
the grid was supposed to have been
expanded but now we have 14 turbines and
no way of getting the electricity on
shore that's obviously not a good
scenario
up to now heligoland has mainly
attracted daytrippers who come here for
a stroll do a bit of shopping and then
return to the mainland
some also stay overnight but
increasingly the island's hotels are
busy with guests from the offshore
sector rather than tourists
at first detlev richmond was skeptical
but now he's very involved
we run it but it was built by the group
from brunswick
and it belongs to them
it belongs to them rwe has leased some
while these 12 apartments are rented by
repower
my basic idea is to get involved in the
offshore business including renting
rooms and apartments long term
that would be really lucrative for me at
the moment fifty percent of our capacity
is rented out to offshore workers
it's noticeable how much things are
changing first dad needs a lot more
apartments and people on the mainland
friends of mine have started coming up
to me and asking me what's happening
here
and my grandparents notice when an
offshore company goes bankrupt and they
ask me whether dad is involved at all
so things are really changing
has spent 30 million euros on the new
southport its biggest single investment
the energy companies are busy with the
next phase of the project by spring the
maintenance facilities should be ready
this is where the offshore technicians
will store their equipment
heligoland's mayor jurg singer is
driving the change in the island's
economy
heligoland is currently sailing very
close to the wind in terms of spending
and costs
but i think that offshore wind farms
will be part of germany's transition to
renewable energies
it'll boost our energy producing
capacity and we'll need that if we're
really serious about phasing out nuclear
power will be stefan schroeder's
responsibility to maintain the wind
turbines over the coming years
the job is well paid and permanent
now it's time to go back we've had a
good day no one's been hurt nothing has
broken down everything's fine
part of the attraction of the job is
that it has an element of adventure
chef and schroeder and his colleagues
are the island's new guests heligoland
has set its course for a future with
wind power